foreign
[Music]
I had a pretty normal childhood in some
regards but I think in other regards I
made myself small
[Music]
my mom was raised in a house the
schizophrenic father
and back in the 1950s there wasn't
really a word for schizophrenia
so she had a ton of pts untreated trauma
and that was brought into the house as
well
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
did you know what you were getting into
when you got married I absolutely did I
knew who I had is and what I was walking
into
[Music]
I'm Jen satterly I am the CEO and
co-founder of all secure Foundation I
grew up in St Louis in kind of an
average family middle class
when I was in high school my dream was
to be a National Geographic photographer
I loved photography actually my father
introduced me to photography when I was
about nine and he was a huge Enthusiast
and it was very passionate about it and
I'll never forget he handed me his
camera his Nikon and let me change the
lens and explore in the backyard with it
and I thought this is it this is what I
want to do I want to take pictures my
dad had tons Stacks and stacks of
National Geographic Magazines so I would
study the photos the people
I just saw Adventure before me and a
whole world that would open to me to be
a photographer not only that but I loved
getting to know people and I had this
protection of the lens
in my 20s I landed on Advertising I
thought that was probably more practical
and then Landing the job as a National
Geographic photographer thought I could
still shoot I could still use my
creative
talents in that Arena
and started my own Farm loved it I got
to travel all over the world again I got
to hear people's stories I got to
photograph them I got to film them and
so to a degree I felt like I I did get
to live that National Geographic
lifestyle although it wasn't quite as
adventurous around the world as I hoped
and it wasn't really until I met Tom and
I started working Along Special
Operations that I felt like I got to
check that box in some capacity
when I met Tom he was
telling me about these things called rmp
realistic military training exercises
[Music]
foreign on the first one with my camera
and my gear
that first experience of going on an rmt
and seeing it I thought this is my
National Geographic moment I'm I'm
literally filming guys right above my
head fast roping down out of a Black
Hawk as explosions are going up and
we're moving through cities it was
something I never
even imagined I would see nonetheless
get to film
when I first started dating Tom he is
very Charming charismatic funny no one
has ever made me laugh more than Tom and
I love to laugh
and he was a good time he always was the
guy at first guy at the bar last guy to
leave the guy telling the jokes the guy
that everyone's kind of crowding around
at the bar and at work it was the same
way everyone respected him a ton and
when he went into work mode I respected
him a ton he became very calm kind of
very quiet and just held the respect of
the room and that's the version I fell
in love with
but as we started dating
the pts symptoms started to become more
and more outward and they became more
visible it was this Jekyll and Hyde type
of Personality where one minute he'd be
charming and funny and charismatic and
loving and tender in the next minute
literally with the flip of a switch he's
violent aggressive mean manipulative and
it was really confusing really confusing
and frustrating for someone like me who
has spent her life making herself small
in order to avoid those kind of
conflicts being raised that way is
always had taught me to to retreat to
surrender
[Music]
children and and Ruby was in major mom
mode and I didn't really drink at all
and then I started working along this
world where drinking was not only
acceptable it was encouraged and so I
started drinking more I started hanging
out more at the bars and it just kind of
became a normal part of our relationship
and where it started to becoming not
normal is when he started lying about it
and starting to hide it because it was
excessive but I had gotten in the habit
of going yep let's go get a drink or two
drink or two became four five six seven
eight and watching that
was heartbreaking because I knew
I knew it was tanking him
our wedding night was not like the
typical wedding night that a girl dreams
of but we went out and we met up with
some of the people that we worked with
and some friends in Savannah and
downtown and the drinks just kept
flowing and when we got up to her room
he was in full anger mode he was lashing
out he was throwing things across the
room screaming every kind of name even
had knocked me over a few times and I I
think I maybe got an hour of sleep that
night and to the point where he woke up
and I was sitting there looking at him
and I just said I don't know if I can do
this I love you and I want to do this
but I don't know if I can and I left on
that Sunday morning
knowing I wouldn't leave him but knowing
that if something didn't change
immediately like Monday and I don't mean
like his pts would be gone on Monday but
that he would take active steps on
Monday that I couldn't stay with someone
who could hurt me
[Music]
didn't know it's hurting me as well
[Music]
Monday morning I got a call from Tom and
he said he had gotten an appointment
like had begged this therapist to fit
him in and I think literally that day
like that afternoon he went and saw
someone
the first thing I saw in him was A
Renewed hope in himself that he trusted
himself in a way that I hadn't really
seen before he was making better choices
and to this day I think he's done nine
or ten different types of therapies and
treatments which is necessary with
complex pts there's not one thing that
can take care of all of it I've been so
proud of him for tackling each and every
treatment just like he's done everything
in his career 100 focus and dedication
and it was a beautiful thing to watch
his healing process and you know that's
still continuing to this day
[Music]
he wasn't in a place where he really
could get the help that he needed the
fog of the alcohol abuse
just improper decision making and we
didn't even know that it was an injury
we thought that this was a life sentence
something that Tom would have to live
with in battle
for the rest of his life and while he'll
never forget what happened in war it's
not like there's any treatment that can
erase memories and take it all away and
I don't know that you would even want to
would you would you want to erase your
your War past our memories no I think
that's just an excuse or another reason
not to start getting help right
self-assessment self-awareness
something in my life I don't like
something I need to change right now how
do I change it what time frame do I want
to change by and then start monitoring
that right but you have growth progress
you'll fall back but you have to have
self-awareness you have to be self-aware
of the issue and desire to not say well
I'd miss combat I love combat I'm built
for combat okay well we're not in combat
when I was working with Special
Operations they started noticing a
difference in Tom he had lost 65 pounds
he was you know showing up to work in a
much better place you could even see it
physically beyond the weight just in his
face the way way he carried himself and
people noticed and they started asking
hey what is Tom doing and I would say
hey have you ever heard about you know
Transcendental Meditation no well here's
the website check it out you know it
just started sharing Resources with
these guys and and really the
interesting thing is we would sit on
these targets for hours and hours and
hours for days and days and weeks and I
just started getting to know the guys
started sharing their stories and
opening up and why I would hear about
some combat trauma that it's not what
was coming forward mostly what was
coming forward mostly was I don't know
how to be a good father I don't know how
to be a good husband I do this job
really really well and I'm trained for
it I have a manual for it I know what to
do and I've got the guy to my left and
right that's going to help me if I don't
know what to do but when I go home I'm
all alone and I don't have a manual and
I don't know what to do
it was in 2016 on the last exercise that
I had done the last rmt and I pulled Tom
aside and I said I want to start a
non-profit because I frankly didn't want
to send guys off to war anymore I didn't
want to watch it I didn't want to
participate in it was breaking my heart
over and over and over again not just
the loss that I was seeing but truly
seeing people come back different people
that I had seen rotation after rotation
they were coming back different
different and different 28 years old
looking 48 years old just in a matter of
three years and two divorces had gone by
and I thought I can't do this anymore I
can't help our men and women go off to
fight I need to help them come home
somebody has to help them come home they
deserve it and so do their families
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
what's the process Monday and they've
been waiting how long
uh secure Foundation serves Special
Operation Warriors and their families
and healing from complex pts and
secondary PTS
nobody should have to battle this alone
it's no different than breaking your arm
if you break your arm you're going to
see a doctor you're going to get
treatment for it and you're going to get
better and it's the exact same thing
with pts when you have an injury due to
trauma treat it immediately and you'll
get better from it the longer you wait
or shoving under the rug doesn't work it
gets worse with time not better
I'll secure Foundation was founded from
truly a hope that we can join families
together families that have been broken
and torn apart by War people look at us
and they think oh it's America we're not
a war-torn country but we absolutely are
it just looks a little bit different if
I could say anything to anyone who's
watching today that may be hurting reach
out for help number one to a family
member who's struggling we're here for
you as well you don't have to go this
alone
foreign
foreign
[Music]